okay so we are back let's take a look at
the many things that Tesla discovered or
invented but sometimes didn't fully get
credit for number one Radio many people
mistakenly think that glamma Marconi was
the inventor of radio to this day
however his work was based on the work
done by Nikola Tesla Tesla theorized
that radio waves could transmit
information as far back as 1893 in
lecture demonstrations in 1898 Tesla
demonstrated a radio-controlled boat
which he dubbed telly automation that
kind of sounds pretty standard today but
you have to understand that this was
1898 the crowd that witnessed the
demonstration was so shocked that they
literally claimed Tesla was using magic
telepathy or had a trained monkey hidden
inside controlling the boat when Marconi
became world famous for sending the
first transatlantic message Tesla said
the following Marconi is a good fellow
let him continue he is using 17 of my
patents number to x-ray this one's a
pretty interesting story x-rays were
discovered by Tesla before Wilhelm
röntgen was credited with the discovery
in fact Tesla took the very first x-ray
photos for some reason after Wilhelm
claimed discovery it was believed that
x-rays could cure blindness and other
ailments
despite Tesla warning that x-rays could
be dangerous Edison tested it on one of
his employees Clarence
Dulli who after having his arms
amputated eventually died from cancer
Edison also fired x-rays into his own
eyes during experiments when questioned
about it in 1903 Edison said don't talk
to me about x-rays I'm afraid of them
number three hydro electricity Tesla
designed the first hydroelectric plant
that was powerful enough to light a city
at Niagara Falls proving to the world
that waterfalls could make a practical
energy source on a large scale a lot of
people told him that it wouldn't
but Tesla had already envisioned how a
generator could harness energy from
moving water when he was still a child
people were shocked but also delighted
to see his vision power whole major US
cities number four the earthquake
machine Tesla created a little
pocket-sized machine that when placed on
a building in wall street and set to the
building's natural frequency made the
structure wobble so much that steel
workers came down to the ground in a
panic believing that there must have
been an earthquake when the police were
called
Tesla put the device back in his pocket
and walked away test the claim that if
he had ten minutes more he could have
laid that building to the ground and
using the same device could have dropped
the Brooklyn Bridge in less than one
hour Tesla also figured out the resonant
frequency of the earth 50 years before
the technology allowed scientists to
catch up with his discovery and lastly
the Tesla Tower so far the previous
inventions were all things that made it
to reality but one of Tesla's most
ambitious projects was actually a
failure although now it's become a Tesla
legend forever romanticized
I'm of course talking about the famous
Wardenclyffe Tower otherwise known as
the Tesla Tower set to deliver free
energy to the world by using the Earth's
ionosphere
as part of the transmission device or
was it the story goes that financial
backer JP Morgan shut the project down
when he discovered it wouldn't make any
money
this isn't entirely true that Tesla had
actually sold the project to Morgan as a
wireless communications tower not as a
means of producing or transmitting
energy the financial backing from JP
Morgan was only pulled when Marconi sent
the first radio waves across the
Atlantic making Morgan change his mind
the project dragged on without Morgan
and ran way over time and ridiculously
over budget until it finally collapsed
aside from this what in science today
says that the Tesla tower wouldn't have
worked this is mainly due to
technicalities such as energy loss
during transmission and Tesla's
misunderstanding of the physics of radio
waves
this was Tesla's first major failure
which brought him great shame this would
set him on a downward path that
eventually led to the decline of the
legend more on this later in the video
all right so we're almost at the end of
the video but before we begin to
conclude let's take a look at four facts
about Tesla number one Tesla loved
humanity as a humanist Tesla believed in
improving the quality of human life but
not for financial gains he is a quote
from Tesla himself money doesn't mean as
much to me as it does to others all my
money has gone into inventions to make
man's life a little easier number two
Tesla envisioned a wireless Internet in
1901 while Tesla was developing the
transatlantic radio he envisioned a
system of collecting information
encoding it and broadcasting that
information to a handheld device this is
basically what we have now as the mobile
internet on our phones pretty impressive
for site for 1901 number 3 Tesla
actually lost everything at one stage as
Tesla was working tirelessly and
discovering many things about wireless
energy transfer his lab burnt down in a
fire forcing him to start his entire
life's work all over again
number 4 Tesla may have had obsessive
compulsive behavior and insomnia Tesla
claimed that he only needed two hours of
sleep a night it's unclear whether that
was because he wanted to or because he
couldn't actually sleep any more than
that Tesla was also obsessed with the
number three and used 18 napkins to
clean his dining room before eating his
evening meals
he also detested round objects jewelry
shaking hands and touching hair
as you can tell by that last fact being
such a genius and having a mind that was
activated to such a high degree came
with some consequences his great mind
became his downfall
Tesla's life story of rise to
international prestige and fame was
followed by an equally dramatic retreat
into public shame depression and
loneliness denial of his failures
starting with the Tesla Tower led to
further failure and further denial a
downward spiral which eventually led
Tesla to a mental breakdown by the
latter part of his life he was
clinically insane Tesla hallucinating to
such an extent that the boundaries
between reality and his imagination
became blur this caused him to work
alone in this lab tirelessly he often
stated that his lab was the only place
where he was truly happy as an example
of his mental condition he is a quote
from one of Nikola Tesla's final
interviews I have been feeding pigeons
thousands of them for years but there
was one pigeon a beautiful bird pure
white with light gray tips on the wings
that one was different
no matter where I was that pigeon would
find me when I wanted her I had only to
wish and call her and she would come
flying to me
I loved that pigeon I loved her as much
as a man loves a woman and she loves me
then one night as I was lying in my bed
in the dark solving problems as usual
she flew through the open window and
stood at my desk and knew she wanted to
tell me something important so I got up
and went to her as I looked at her and
you she wanted to tell me she was dying
and then as I got her message there came
a light from her eyes powerful beams of
light I don't think there's anything
else to say there over his lifetime
Tesla had obtained more than 100 patents
and 700 inventions but despite all of
this he was dirt poor
for many years he worked alone in this
room at the hotel New Yorker where he
died in 1943 living on a diet of milk
and Nabisco crackers so a lot of you
would be asking how did this happen
how did Tesla end up so poor it is true
Tesla could have been the world's first
billionaire by a longshot but he just
really didn't care about money he is an
example after the War of the currents
Westinghouse was in trouble
they were almost bankrupt and about to
go under so Westinghouse pleaded with
Tesla to temporarily cut back his
royalties just so the Westinghouse
company could get through this tough
time and survive shockingly Tesla ripped
up the contract right there and then on
the spot this would have amounted to
three hundred billion dollars for Tesla
Tesla simply stated that he was just
happy that Westinghouse believed in him
when no one else would I guess having a
huge part in changing the world was
enough of a reward in itself for him the
rest of the remaining money that Tesla
had accumulated over his life all got
spent on numerous failed projects such
as the Tesla Tower Tesla's ideas helped
America grow into an industrial nation
and a powerhouse of the 20th century yet
his marginalization was prevalent then
and continues today he is almost
non-existent if you look through many of
today's text books this is mainly
because Tesla did not care about profit
fame or fortune he only wanted to make
the world a better place
this was the polar opposite of most of
the businessmen of that day who
unfortunately took advantage of Tesla's
nature profiting from his work and
leaving him with nothing it could be a
lesson to us all have the purest
intentions but stand up for yourself and
know your
to finish off he is one last quote from
Tesla the present is theirs the future
for which I have really worked is mine
and that is the story of Nikola Tesla
thanks for watching guys hope you enjoy
that video on Nikola Tesla please give
this video a thumbs up share it to
someone who would like to know the story
or who would be interested in that and
definitely subscribe if you also you
might want to check out my last video on
General Electric I was pretty
interesting I'd also like to give a
shout-out and a special thank you to own
car and his team from the curious
engineer who did some of the
illustrations for this video I'll leave
a link to the curious engineers channel
down below so please feel free to check
that out and subscribe to that channel
thanks for helping out man also if you
want to help this channel make better
videos and more frequent videos please
consider supporting cold fusion on
patreon ok so that's all from me thanks
for watching guys this has been to gogo
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll see you again soon for the next
video cheers guys have a good one cold
Killian
it's rethinking